it's morning in Middle America and like
thousands of others like her jenna is on
her way to college general still a
freshman and she's settling in well but
one thing does worry her next year the
state of Kansas will allow students to
carry guns at college as a daughter
Syrian immigrants Jenna tells us she
fears her headscarf could make her a
target all it takes is one person that
has hatred in their heart or has
negative intentions and I don't know how
comfortable I would be with everyone
being able to carry out deadly weapon so
easily but guns are a reality here in
Wichita the biggest city in the
heartland state of Kansas this is Trump
country but it's also home to more than
9,000 Muslims many of them moved here to
work at firms like Boeing and says 'no
which it has skyline bears that out
alongside the factories and churches a
large mosque now also stands proud Jenna
knows what role she wants to play in
this community she wants to be a
journalist she's already making a start
as a reporter for her college newspaper
the sunflower she and her team spent
long hours down here in their basement
newsroom she says American journalism
needs perspectives like hers
as a journalist when you're going to
cover a story you always you're always a
part of the picture you know you're
never really truly objective you're
always bringing your your background in
your history to the story and that
affects the way you look at the people
you're talking to the situation you're
observing and I think it's important to
have people of different backgrounds for
that reason because two people can look
at the same situation and cover it
entirely differently jenna is especially
proud of her reporting on a big dispute
that broke out over the college chapel
last year the student body decided to
replace its permanent pues with folding
chairs so Muslims and other religious
groups could also use the space for
worship the college had no objections
but a backlash soon followed fox news
even claimed it was an act of Christian
cleansing Jenna deeply disagrees
this is a public university I think it's
questionable in the first place to have
a chapel at all on campus since it is a
state school but if we're going to have
one it definitely shouldn't should be
you know nann not aligned with one
particular religion you should
definitely be open to everyone now
Islam's place in America is at the
center of this year's poisonous
presidential campaign what will the
effect beyond Jenna and her friends
they've already been the target of
harassment in the street shouts that
they could take off their head scarves
and go home it's a bit confusing to me
when people say Muslims don't belong in
the United States just because Muslims
have been in this country since you know
George Washington's time and as for me
personally I was born in the United
States this is my home so when people
tell me to go back to where I came from
like where should I go like this is this
is where I come from as America chooses
what direction that wants to take Jenna
knows that she has to fight for her
place in it but she believes in America
the country that she loves the country
that she calls home